ready get set go BMW is celebrating the
40th anniversary of its popular 3-series
since their debut in 1975 these cars
have developed a reputation as solid
compacts that are fun to drive there
have been six generations of three
series cars and each has been built on
the success of its predecessor the third
generation featured a completely new
design a distinctive wedge shape the
wheelbase was extended by 13 centimeters
making for a more spacious passenger
compartment and BMW kept designing new
3-series body styles including sedans
convertibles who pays touring cars and
the motorsport version
the fifth generation came out with an
impressive array of innovations in the
engine and chassis and it was more
comfortable
the latest 3 Series generation will pick
up right where the fifth generation left
off
my nest I automotive journalist
hans-joachim vague says BMW has
sharpened its focus in all the right
places for the sixth generation the
engines are more efficient the
suspension is improved and all-round
full LED lights have been added the
sixth generation BMWs may not inspire
oohs and aahs but then they weren't
intended to at night the optional full
LED headlights really stand out but
optically the design is more reserved
and that's not a bad thing the 3-series
have always been icons of style
we took a top-of-the-line 340 I out for
a test drive is powered by a 240
kilowatt twinpower turbo inline
six-cylinder engine
BMW didn't change much and the design of
the passenger compartment the chrome
accents are still there lending as ever
a quiet grace to the interior
the moto and joakim reg points out that
the advantages of the 340 ice
high-performance 326 horsepower engine
and adds that this engine runs a lot
more efficiently than previous designs
fuel consumption can easily hit 9 litres
per 100 kilometers bevel condesa auto
loka want annoying little baby it's not
easy to combine that kind of horsepower
with fuel efficiency but BMW was up to
the task BMW itself rates fuel
consumption at 6.8 liters the new 340 I
has also cut co2 emissions by eleven
percent over the previous generation
what's me I'm more inclined conshohocken
vague says he really likes the
improvements BMW has made to the
suspension that makes for an especially
smooth and comfortable ride but it also
has good stability and traction going
into curves ines their whole corn
stubble eat it about twenty-five percent
of all new BMW sold our 3 Series models
there's a wide variety of engine options
to choose from for gasoline and seven
diesel powered models ranging from 85 to
240 kilowatts these cars range from 30
thousand two hundred to just under fifty
seven thousand euros in Germany bobito
antioch am really likes the way the BMW
has re-engineered the 3-series he's
particularly impressed with a wide range
of engine options from the
three-cylinder 5.1 litre to the 240
kilowatt 340 I mitzvah enough Itzik kavi